und leute kurze anmerkung das natürlich
nur spaß hat eine freundin
heute fast glaubt willkommen beim ein
video im jahr wir haben gerade ungelogen
schon fast wieder ein uhr und ich muss
dieses video heute noch aufnehmen weil
ich morgen nach köln fahren über morgen
bin ich auch in köln und übermorgen
sondern schon das video kommen und ich
hoffe wir kriegen es jetzt noch oft die
kette irgendwen zu finden der jetzt noch
wach es denn ich habe mich natürlich mal
wieder was ganz besonderes für euch
überlegt und zwar sind ja die letzten
beiden whatsup rang so gut bei euch
angekommen der letzte hat auch schon
wieder locker über 15.000 dax macht
erstmal danke dafür und großem applaus
und da habe ich mir natürlich gedacht
ich komm' haus doch einfach direkt jetzt
meinen dritten teil raus und ich suche
mir jetzt ein mädchen aus meiner stufe
raus beziehungsweise eine gute freundin
von mir also nur normale freundin und
schreibt einmal so ein bisschen was von
let's talk about merke ich denke kennt
alle den song wie heißt let's talk about
sex baby letzter gewollt you and me
nancy bird ein kurzer einblick
ok danke reicht auch schon ihr wisst was
ich meine um mit der deutschen
übersetzung davon fange ich jetzt sofort
war nachdem ich ich muss jetzt erstmal
wieder raussuchen die scheiße ist auch
ich hab neues handy und habe noch gar
nicht so viele nummern wenn es jetzt
nicht klappt dann bin ich traurig er
damit nicht richtig traurig ich schreibe
jetzt einfach mal ein paar freundinnen
von mir an einfach so mit hell und dann
so ein 2 1 2
die nokia noch die so laut ich habe
jetzt vier meter angeschrieben und ich
warte jetzt einfach mal ob irgendeine
von den antworten
hey ich glaub ich fange jetzt besseren
nicht an ich schreibe einfach erstmal so
noch warum noch was sie schreibt auf
jeden fall schon warum brauchst du so
lange ich war noch eingeladen auf einer
feier von meiner familie aber bin schon
total mädel absolut okay merck hat noch
eine zweite geschrieben egal warum ist
man jetzt noch wach wir haben einfach
mittwochabend gerade der wahrscheinlich
auch nix zu tun genauso wie ich nur
youtube ist einfach beste live server
gibt ich fange jetzt einfach mal sofort
an
sie schreibt noch okay ich war noch kurz
auf die antwort und dann fange ich an
mit diesem let's talk about sex juni
diese bestien und du wie kommt es dass
du dich meldest richtig lange nichts von
dir gehört
da kann sie auch mal selber melden ich
fange jetzt einfach an
hätte ich vielleicht erst schreiben
sollen ich muss dir was sagen noch nicht
dinge können sind
ich hoffe das wird so geil mal sehen was
das finde ich jetzt
ich würde am liebsten im sport schon
wieder aufhören ok nein leute mir hat ja
noch eine andere freundin geantwortet
also hey hey warum schreibt mädchen
eigentlich immer nicht kay sondern hey
jetzt mache ich das extra
wie gehen
komik hat auch irgendwie ein bisschen
scheiße vor weil ich bin eigentlich gar
nicht der typ der so irgendwelche
mädchen an schreibt gefragt wie steam
geht gut gut und dir so ich fange jetzt
einfach sofort an auch ich muss dir da
mal was sagen mit kuss miley ich hoffe
das video sieht meine freundin nicht
okay
was meinst du wir haben uns seit fast
einem halben jahr nicht mehr gesehen so
ich hoffe jetzt konnte ich sie fest dass
sie sich fragte was meint er und dass
sie mir sofort antworten weil wir mich
nicht was meinst du
ich stelle mir gerade vor jetzt kommen
wirklich ihre dunkelsten fantasien
ich glaube du verwechselst gerade etwas
er jetzt kommt das beste cool wäre ja
auch wenn sie jetzt so voll drauf
eingehen würde und leute kurze anmerkung
das natürlich nur spaß ich habe eine
freundin und das ist gut es kann nur
angesprochen habe alex du hast doch eine
freundin auf dem bild sieht man das war
was meint ihr dazu findest du das witzig
schon du bist vergeben
so etwas macht man nicht dass es nur ein
song leuten also das ist eigentlich
würde ich sowas niemals schreiben
ok jetzt habe ich doch leicht schlechtes
gewissen da war ich doch wohl ein
bisschen zu sehr von mir überzeugt wir
machen weiter vor schluss mit dir allein
und lass mich in ruhe habe echt kein
merkel so etwas also so gemein habe ich
dich gar nicht eingeschätzt was drauf
leute jetzt kommt das absolute highlight
das ist jetzt schon echt leicht krank so
aber gut
entweder du bist total betrunken auf
drogen oder einfach nur krank geworden
lass mich einfach in ruhe ja oder
schreibt mir wenn du normal bist eine
frage noch das war bis jetzt eigentlich
der beste website bringt von mir
du warst du nicht lassen kannst du es
reicht sonst blockiere ich dich das
testen wir jetzt gleich mal aus jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt ob sie es wirklich
macht danke leute was mache ich denn
jetzt muss ich eigentlich sagen das war
nur spaß so klar geworden eigentlich
wenn ich sie jetzt heute nicht mehr
erreiche wird sie bestimmt zehn stunden
von mir denken was bin ich für krank am
end ich versuche einfach morgen noch mal
das nehme ich dann morgen noch auf heute
kurzer beitrag oder nachtrag noch zu
meinem whatsup rang ich bin heute schon
in köln gewesen ich bin ja auch in köln
ihr könnt euch heute lassen kannst ja
mal kurz zeigen ein fünf sterne luxus
appartement rassehund auf jeden fall
wollte ich noch mal kurz jetzt
klarstellen weil ich keine zeit hatte
meine
schulfreundin auf anzurufen dass ich das
jetzt einfach mal schnell nochmal
versuchen
warum hast du mich warum hast du mich
bei whatsapp blockiert das war nur spaß
kennst du keine whatsapp kannst du keine
whatsapp ranks du weißt auch immer schon
bei mir im youtube-video sein erstes mal
geschafft da willst du ja ja also kannst
du mich bitte wieder deblockieren weil
es halt nur spaß war so das war nicht
ernst hast du gedacht ich meine es ernst
du bist bisschen iq von dem toast seine
leute ich mache jetzt hier mal stopp ich
hoffe dass wieder hat euch gefallen und
jetzt muss ich mir wahrscheinlich noch
ein bisschen jetzt bisschen das gelaber
hier an alle leute das verlust spaß ich
hoffe natürlich erste trotzdem spaß beim
anschauen
und ich habe eine klare steigerung zu
verzeichnen finde ich was dieses wort
zur brinks angeht ich meinen guckt man
sich bei den letzten beiden partnern
wenn es noch nicht gesehen hat weiß in
der video beschreibung verlinken sieht
man so eine krasse kurve bei 15.000
likes auf diesem video kommt natürlich
noch ein vierter teil wirklich mega
freuen wenn er da auch natürlich noch
bock drauf ab und wir sehen uns dann am
sonntag wieder beim ein video um 14 uhr
denkmal hard rain folgten auf instagram
wenn es noch nicht tut und macht so weit
nicht also doch macht was auch das ist
cool